un grito de victoria de los talibanes en
la ciudad de ghazni
a 150 km al suroeste de kabul es la
décima capital de provincia que cae en
las manos de los insurgentes su ofensiva
que comenzó en mayo avanza a un ritmo
desenfrenado pero washington ya no está
haciendo frente a los rebeldes y el
gobierno afgano deberá asegurar su
propia seguridad
continuamos con los ataques aéreos en
apoyo de las fuerzas afganas pero como
ha indicado el presidente de byd en los
dirigentes afganos deben unirse el
futuro de su país descansa en sus
hombros los talibanes ya habían
conseguido tomar el control de la ciudad
de faisalabad en la provincia de
badajshán en la frontera con tayikistán
pakistán y china desde el viernes pasado
los talibanes han tomado control de
estas 10 capitales de provincia la
última de ellas gas ni por donde pasa
una importante carretera que une kabul
con el sur del territorio el miércoles
el presidente asad cani estuvo en la
asediada ciudad de mazar-i-sharif al
norte intentando coordinar una retoma
mientras tanto en doha qatar avanzan las
conversaciones para intentar relanzar un
proceso de paz que se encuentra en punto
muerto
a la vez decenas de miles van llegando a
kabul y otros tantos intentan salir del
país desde el comienzo del año más de
390.000 personas han sido desplazadas
por el conflicto en el país con un pico
registrado en mayo de acuerdo con
algunas estimaciones unos dos tercios de
actuales tam estarían bajo control
mientras la retirada de las tropas
estadounidenses avanza a gran ritmo y
estaría completa para el 31 de agosto